One of my favorite parts of this job
is meeting extraordinary people doing extraordinary things.
It is such a mission of the show.
It's so much of what this show is all about.
And I recently had the honor of surprising
an incredible teacher from Chicago.
Who's going above and beyond for her students.
Please take a look at Megan.
Hi, my name is Megan Faherty.
I'm a Pre-K teacher at Schubert Elementary School
in Chicago, and I've been teaching for eight years.
Teaching preschool is really special and unique
because every day looks different.
Everything is really hands-on
and we want everything to be really tangible for the kids.
The way that I teach is very emergent and child led.
That means no two days look the same.
Part of the magic of preschool is that kids are so curious.
They are naturally explorers.
And when you can foster that and facilitate it,
every day is really exciting.
I have learned so much
working in the Chicago public school system
and have seen a lot of things
that are amazing and wonderful.
And I've also seen a lot of things
that I think need to change.
Our school does the best they can as far as supplies go,
but everything we use is consumable.
So we are running out of supplies all the time.
Teaching is a wonderful, beautiful job
where I get to work with amazing kids.
The impact that you can make, not only on academics,
but on students' social, emotional wellbeing,
and having a safe space and building a community
in your classroom, it makes me really proud to be a teacher.
(upbeat music)
I don't mean to scare you,
but I might scare you out.
Oh, my God.
Hi, Megan.
How are you?
It's so great.
I'm good.
It's so nice to see you.
I'm so excited.
I know that you're responsible for this hallway.
Yeah.
Well, I think you've picked really beautiful colors.
Thank you.
We have such amazing kids
and this building is Pre-K and K.
So, you know, my principal and I had talked about it
and we wanted to reflect the kids
and for them to be a part of it.
And they even had a say in picking out paint colors
and stuff.
I love that.
And all of these like banners and stuff that you see,
those are all different book covers.
So we had different features, pick them out and design them.
We have five pre-K classrooms
and two of them are dual language classrooms.
I have every one of these books.
So that's what makes me feel so cozy
and happy being in here as my two daughters.
Frankie's now in first grade and Olive in third,
and I just miss the days of preschool and kindergarten.
I'm so interested in why you felt that education
was so important.
Cause I was reading that you didn't necessarily think
maybe when you were a kid,
you were gonna be a teacher.
No, no.
Is that true?
I actually went Columbia College, Chicago,
which is an art school.
That's right.
So I had initially gone into painting
and just kind of to develop credit,
took an education class and the professor and the course
and the way that they view children as so capable
and the magic that I got to see in preschool classroom,
I was like this is it.
Do you ever feel like,
I feel like my kids are like a fresh start.
Like there's so much hope this formative, shaping
and time is so crucial and important to them.
Absolutely, I'm learning law and policy
so that I can work in advocacy for children
and families within the education system.
Interesting.
Yeah.
So you can advocate for families and children?
Within the education system, yeah.
How are you finding the time to do that?
It's a lot of work, but it's work that I love.
I'm really enjoying it for right now, for sure.
Well, I love your intentions and I love your life choices.
And I love that your path has led you to these places.
(crowd claps)
(crowd applause)
Oh, I love Megan so much.
We had such a beautiful day together.
(crowd applause)
So before the break met an amazing Chicago teacher
named Megan, who I had the pleasure of surprising her
at her school,
but that wasn't the only thing we had in store.
No, no, much bigger and more important things.
Take a look.
I love being in this part of the school
because well, there's this aspect.
(crowd applause)
I can feel your energy from a mile away.
And everybody wanted to show up to say that they support you
honor you, love you.
I can't thank you guys enough for showing up
for Megan today so that she can see that.
(crowd applause)
Shannon, please come up, talk to Megan.
This is your sister.
I'm like a fly on wall moment.
Sis, I think you are an inspiration to not only me,
but everyone here, you know, as an older sister
you are one of the most compassionate
and understanding people ever,
you've taught me so much about myself and about education,
you know, I think that as a teacher, an educator,
you inspire me, seeing how much you works through students
and just, you know, how much you give back
and your selflessness say something like, I don't know.
if I get in a small bit of that as a teacher,
I'd call myself lucky.
When you came to Schubert School,
you walked into a classroom
where the children went through six different substitutes
and nobody wanted to stay with that class of children
because they said they were rowdy.
And two weeks later I came in to your room
and it was a carpet just like this.
And the children were all seated in front of a screen
and they were all signing in sign language.
What a wonderful world.
And the thing is, Megan,
is that you not only stayed at Schubert,
you saved those children.
Those children needed stability and love
and a person that would be there and be dedicated for them.
And that what you gave to them.
I wanna invite us all to sit down.
Cause as you sit down,
luckily something else will happen too.
This is one element of today.
Joann Stores is going to donate
$10,000 worth of art supplies to you.
(crowd applause)
And they also want to give you $10,000.
For you, Megan.
Thank you so much.
As well, thank you Joann so much, Joann stores.
Thank you, Joann.
And, you know, I have to say, when you talked about
how, when kids, oh,
when they just don't have that stability and that structure
and they're craving it and, you know,
whether they're your kids personally or not
like where do you drum up the love
and compassion and the time and the commitment
to get in there.
What do you summon inside of yourself
that could teach us all?
Kids are really capable.
And if we give them the space,
when they're having those big behaviors
or they need support in that way,
there's no such thing as a bad four year old
or a five year old or six year old,
they're communicating to us
that their needs are not being met.
It's also about trusting kids and listening
and not just walking in a room to teach them,
but being really open to what they can teach you.
I can see how you make people feel safe.
And that is one of the most powerful things
we can have in this life of great uncertainty.
And maybe that's why we need it so much.
So thank you, for being who you are, by the way,
I'm really sorry if I smell like hot dogs,
they just came from Jimmy's
(crowd laughs)
And I had two hot dogs and I'm like, well, Megan,
what do you think that your first art project
is to kind of attack with all your news supplies
and your kids?
You know, I would have to ask the kids.
(crowd laughs)
Thank you guys so, so, so, so much.
Thank you so much.
It's unbelievable.
Thank you so much for everything
(crowd applause)
Megan, thank you.
Thank you for all that you do.
(upbeat music)